so am i audible okay
today i will be talking about a variant
of noisy channel
we call it elastic noisy channels
and i will explain how we can construct
secure multi-party computation protocols
efficiently over these more realistic
noisy channel models
this is joint work with dashita kurana
and amit sahai
and in the talk first i will introduce
what elastic noisy channels are
and then i will explain how we build
secure multi-party computation protocols
efficiently over them
and
the crucial part which underlies or the
privacy arguments of our construction is
this new information theoretic phenomena
called uh
capacity inversion
so i will explain this
uh using some examples we won't be going
into
strict mathematical formulations
so to begin let me just go ahead and
explain what
elastic noisy channels are in fact
so suppose we have cell phones and we
want to use them as
weak transmitters and receivers to
perform secure multiparty computation
a transmitter might be transmitting a
sequence of bits and a receiver since it
is a weak receiver might not receive
each bit perfectly in this case say a
third of the bits are erased
but the receiver could turn adversarial
this receiver could go ahead and install
a larger antenna
this increases the reliability of
reception at his end
so now the bits are erased only with
probability one by six so in fact what
happens is that some bits which were
erased earlier are not erased
anymore
now
given this additional advantage that
this receiver has
can we still perform secure multiparty
computation because the sender doesn't
know whether it is talking to a honest
receiver or an adversarial receiver
this can be formalized easily as an
elastic version of a binary erasure
channel in a binary eraser channel the
sender sends a bit b and it is delivered
with probability one third if the
receiver is honest otherwise the bit is
erased and if the receiver is
adversarial then the bit is
deliver erased only with probability one
by six
note that the sender doesn't know
whether the bit was dropped or not and
the receiver doesn't know the input bit
if it receives the erased symbol
now this given this model of a elastic
binary eraser channel
our task is to construct oblivious
transfer using such
elastic versions of binary erasure
channel
i want to emphasize that we only want to
construct one i will only show you how
to construct one ot because given this
qualitative result we know how to
convert it into a quantitative result
that is we can construct large number of
ots so we are just interested in the
qualitative result
so such a protocol will have the
following property for correctness if
the sender has private inputs x0 and x1
and the receiver has private input bit c
then we expect the receiver to obtain
the secret x sub c
the privacy of such a protocol should
insist that the sender should not be
able to find out the secret in the
private input of the sender that is the
bit c
on the other hand
a
adversarial receiver should not be able
to find out the other secret that is x 1
minus c
now let me go ahead and give you the
protocol which implements one oblivious
transfer from elastic versions of binary
erasure channel
on the left side we have the sender on
the oh sorry on the right side we have
the sender and on the left side we have
the receiver the sender has private
input bits x0 and x1 and the receiver
has private input bit c
to explain the protocol i will assume
that the choice bit c is zero
first of all the sender sends a large
number of bits through the erasure
channel
and the receiver receives a few of them
and
some of these
bits are erased
in this example
in this case for example a third of the
bits are erased the black bits represent
the bits which have been erased
now
the receiver
partitions the set of the indices 0 1 to
into two parts
such that the first set of indices
comprises of bits
of indices corresponding to bits it has
received
let's
go over this again the receiver randomly
partitions the set 0 to 5 into two equal
subsets such that the first subset
comprises of indices
corresponding to bits which were all
received
now
if c was 1 we would have swapped these
two sets
the receiver sends these two in this uh
the set of indices one zero three and
three two four two four five
to the
sender
the sender sees that the first set
comprises of indices one zero 3 so its
secret shares the secret x 0 as b 1 plus
b 0 plus b 3 and a bit r 0.
next it says the second set as 2 4 5 so
its secret shares x 1 as b 2 plus b 4
plus b 5 plus the bit r1
and now the sender sends these two bits
r0 r1 to the receiver
now we can see that it is easy for the
receiver to
obtain its secret because she already
knows b1 b2b3 and knows r0 so
it can easily recover the secret x sub c
now
this protocol for example it is easy to
see that it is correct but why is it
private
so let us try to argue what about
the receiver privacy
note
that the sender on the only additional
information that the center sees is
these two sets
over the randomness of the initial
channel and over the internal randomness
of the receiver
these two partitions are just a random
partition of the set
into two equal sets of the set 0 1 to
yes 5. this is just a naive question why
don't you just use an error correcting
code uh error correcting code does not
error correcting code removes errors it
cannot ensure privacy
this is in some sense an error
correcting code it's like it is secret
sharing
plus an error correcting code
protocol and then user correcting code
on top of it uh there is no oblivious
transfer protocol we are trying to build
it
that assumption
it's an unconditional result information
theoretic in presence of
forget about multilinear maps
so receiver has constructed these two
sets right
yeah but he has constructed because she
wanted to obtain c0 she has constructed
this set that all it knows all the
secrets
if i wanted c1 i would have constructed
this set with all indices such that it
knows everything
so can you say clearly what is the
assumption about the channel the channel
is that there is a sender and a receiver
and it has two properties alpha and beta
for example alpha is the probability of
erasure when the receiver is honest and
beta is a some smaller probability of
erasure when the receiver is adversarial
for example if you have a ratio channel
if i'm honest i will receive with
probability 33
if i'm adversarial i receive with
probability uh
much higher than 33 percent i receive
the bit identically and then when you
want to on a business transfer you want
two properties when they're honest it
works and when they're this one
it's obviously yeah
you're also assuming uh individual
independent arrangements yes iid
is this clear so the protocol is clear
right
even if the
the receiver isn't cheating though and
just probabilistically they end up
getting more yeah but chennai is low
right
so let me go and go ahead with the
security proof
is it fine or there are more questions
yes
so you know the bound of the p and that
suffices
my point is
is the problem of elastic things the
same as the problem that you have when
it's there isn't t but you just don't
know it or is it at least i know it's uh
slightly different as well like um
so
you can adversely
see in our case there is a strategy of
reaching the highest like suppose
you know that the channel characteristic
lies in the range of alpha to beta
in our case it's a reality that
adversary can install air antenna which
gives it beta
in your case it might not even be
possible
that the the reality might be far from
beta
why did you say turn off it's enough
that you didn't get one bit yes but
enough you'll not get one bit
so let me go ahead with the security
proof
so now let's uh let me argue the sender
security
in this case the receiver is adversarial
so recall that the adversary adversarial
receiver can increase the reliability of
the communication and therefore
i think maybe there are some more
questions for this video so
i'm hearing them
yeah yeah yeah if you have questions yes
this is the most
complicated protocol you'll ever see in
this talk so let's go ahead
replace it by security parameter number
of bits
so the honest receiver must get enough
another reason to actually yes yes i
will uh i will uh formally state that
result in just in the next slide
so
for the sender security recall
that uh
so let me go over to center security
again in this in the case of sender
security the adversarial sender can make
the channel more reliable so some of
these erasures
can actually be received by this
receiver
and now
it has some bits which have been
released for example in this case a
sixth of the bits have been erased to
argue security
let's track
one of the bits which has been erased
in this case the
bit indexed five comes in this set and
i'm going to claim that
this secret the second secret is
perfectly hidden because
this bit b5 is perfectly hidden
because the receiver did not receive the
bit b5 so the receiver cannot recreate
or extract the other bit x1 minus c
so it's a perfect security
if such a bit exists is this argument
clear
maybe you're going to talk about the
late
but i remember there was a work maybe it
was by you which can see that kind of a
more challenging setting of other stereo
letters between in an interval
uh
here also in this case also like if it
is an interval adversarial error it's
also fine
if you introduce adversarial errors
errors yes we'll come to your errors
we'll come to errors
so
now
yeah
you make
you're sending to sure first chart
because your channel is randomized yes
so you send here is a constant number of
bits but assume
i'm sending security parameter number of
bits it's not constant it's security
parameter number of bits and
yes but it's yeah
okay
so now that
we are fine with the security of this
protocol
let me go ahead and state our formal
theorem so if we have alpha beta
okay one more question should i go back
yes it was i said that these are
random partition
you know i can decide where to semi
honest semi honest
okay
as i'm stating it it is semi honest but
our results are can be made adversarial
like against you it's you see
adversities also it is complete like
this construction works and modification
of it
but i won't be going and it's easier
just to motivate using the semi-honest
it's a third party it's a
universe introducing random noise let's
say first of all
the channel is the third person so for
each message somebody has to choose a
number between one and one six how is
this number chosen no
yeah if the if the receiver becomes
adversarial he chooses the channel which
is better
should we move
so
actually what we have proven is that if
you have alpha beta erasure channel that
is alpha is the probability of erasure
when
the receiver is honest and beta is the
probability of eraser when the receiver
is adversarial then
if alpha and beta are less than half
then we can construct oblivious transfer
from such an elastic version of binary
relationship
here we crucially use that at least half
of the symbols arrive
okay
now in fact we can actually increase
this number from half to one using
techniques from error correcting codes
so i'm not going to go into the details
of that
the summary of this slide is that for
any
non-trivial choices of alpha beta
we can construct secure multiparty
computation over such variants of
elastic such elastic variants of binary
eraser channel
yes it can be upgraded to uc secure
protocols it's a uc secure like
questions just just uh
uh
you need the upper bound and alpha to
make sure that that is half
yes and you need the lower bound of beta
for each one is missed
then you can go all the way to half by
repeat like you the obvious thing is to
repeat but you can do efficient more
efficient things
how this relates to this model of unfair
noise
yes
yes so the model of unfair noisy channel
in that both the receiver and the sender
can change the channel characteristic
in this only the receiver can change
they had strong negative impossibility
results because according to me i do not
like believe that that's a very nice
model
and they have very strong impossibility
results in our case i will show you that
very strong possibility feasibility
results are possible
so does the efficiency of the process
will depend on the vehicle
yes
the efficiency and the number of ots
that you will be able to extract depends
on that right so i mean
if beta was negligibly small
negligibly small is useless it's a
trivial channel because it's a
a channel which always reliably delivers
a bit is cryptographically infertile
so you never get that the protocol gets
exponential complexity
yes in that like think of all alphabets
as constants
because
beta is the probability of erasure
for the adversary so adversary wants
more and more information
yes but i'm saying that my protocol
should be better less security or equal
beat up
okay
it's easy chris
like everyone knows that yeah
right yes
the non-trivial
uh forgetting things
so let's go ahead and try to see why
exactly our protocol worked like i gave
you a protocol i gave you proof but why
exactly it's worked
to do that let me introduce the notion
of capacity of a channel intuitively it
means how much
information an output symbol carries
about its input symbol
so suppose we have a channel which
always reliably forwards its input bit
we say that it has capacity one
if you have a channel which always
erases the bit that the input the sender
provides then we say that it has
capacity 0.
now let me show you how we can draw a
graph representing binary original
channels
recall that when the sender sends the
input bit 0 the receiver either receives
0 or the symbol bot and if the sender
sends input bit 1 then the receiver
either receives 1 or bought this
is a graphical representation of a
binary ratio channel
now we can similarly represent the graph
of a message forwarding channel and we
can also represent graphically the
picture of a
message irrigating channel
note
that a binary irrational channel is a
convex linear combination of these two
sub channels
and the capacity of this channel recall
was one and capacity of this channel was
zero and consequently
the capacity of this channel is one
minus epsilon
so
till this point i want to understand
what we have done
we have drawn a picture of binary ratio
channel and then we have decomposed
it into two sub channels with
very different capacities
note that if the receiver is honest
the maximum sub channel capacity is one
of the two channels the maximum sub
channel capacity is one
if the receiver is
adversarial in that case
the average channel capacity that is the
average sub channel capacity is 1 minus
epsilon where epsilon is beta
so the real reason
why our protocol actually remains
private and is a secure implementation
of oblivious transfer is because there
exists a gap between these two numbers
i want to emphasize that we are not
comparing the highest sub channel
capacity with the highest adversarial
subchannel capacity we are not comparing
the average with the average we are
comparing the highest
with the average this is extremely
crucial
so given this abstraction let us try to
use this knowledge on more channels like
binary symmetric channel in a binary
symmetric channel a sender sends a bit b
and with certain probability the bit is
delivered or it is flipped if the
receiver is honest then the bit is
flipped with probability one third and
if the receiver is adversarial then it
is flipped only with probability 1 6.
note that in this case both sender and
receiver do not know whether the input
bit was flipped or not
now
the
elastic version of a binary symmetric
channel can be parameterized by two
parameters alpha and beta
where alpha is the probability that the
input bit is flipped when the receiver
is honest and beta is the probability
that the input bit is flipped when
receiver is
adversarial the question we ask is for
which values of parameters alpha and
beta we can indeed securely implement
oblivious transfer
okay
let's try to use whatever we learned
let's try
to graphically represent oblivio
binary symmetric channel that is simple
we have input with 0 then we get 0 or 1
if you have input bit 1 then you get 1
and 0. but there is no obvious way of
decomposing this graph
into sub graphs or sub channels
such that they have very different
channel capacities
here
it is
so yeah so
here our main idea is that instead of
encoding the message 0 with the bit 0
and encoding a message 1 with a bit 1 we
use this following trick we are going to
encode the message 0 with say
2 repetitions of 0
and the message 1 using 1 1
we are going to send these two bits
through two independent
two independent binary symmetric channel
instances
now the receiver receives one of these
four output symbols
note
that
the top two symbols could be interpreted
as output of a different binary
symmetric channel which takes 0 0 as
input or 1 1 as input
and
the bottom two symbols could be
interpreted as output of a binary
symmetric channel which takes 0 0 or 1 1
as input
in fact this is just a message erasure
channel
it also has the probability
that this channel
has lower capacity than the channel that
we started off with and that channel has
a lower capacity than the channel on the
top
what have we achieved at least we have
achieved our first step we have been
able to break binary symmetric channel
into sub channels such that the sub
channels have very different
capacities
okay but why stop it too right like we
have a good thing going
so why stop at encodings of length two
we can go three four and further
so yes we can do that
we can encode zero with zero zero zero
and we can encode one as one comma one
comma one and pass it through three
repetitions of binary three independent
instances of binary symmetric channel
the receiver receives one of these eight
symbols
and
one can show that
the top two could be interpreted as
outcome of a particular binary symmetric
channel and the bottom 6 symbols could
also be interpreted as output of one
particular binary symmetric channel
so again we have expressed
our original
channel
as a convex linear combination of
different channels such that they have
very different channel capacities
okay the first point is done we have
been able to decompose the channels
but have we ensured that the maximum
honest sub channel capacity surpasses
the average
adversarial sub channel capacity
let me explain that
using a particular example suppose alpha
is one third and beta is one sixth for
this particular value let me show how we
can and
how we can achieve that goal
i will do it using
pictures
so in this picture the y axis is
capacity
the blue rectangles are
sub channels corresponding to
adversarial receiver case
the green rectangles are
capacities of sub channels corresponding
to honest receiver case the x-axis will
be probability that a certain
sub-channel actually is used to process
the input
so when we start we have only one
sub-channel
and the honest maximum subchannel
capacity is significantly lower than the
average adversarial capacity
if you use encodings of length two then
both these quantities increase but
believe me these two actually get closer
to each other what are these two
quantities let's again look at them this
is the maximum capacity in the honest
receiver case and this is the average
capacity in the adversarial receiver
case
so we keep using encodings of greater
and greater length these two keep
getting closer and closer
and at six we are nearly there and if we
use encodings of length seven
surprisingly now what we have is that
the
maximum honest sub channel capacity
surpasses the average adversarial sub
channel capacity
at this point we say that capacity
inversion has taken place and the
encoding which achieves it is known as a
capacity inverting encoding
so if we have a capacity inverting
encoding then we can go ahead and
construct an oblivious transfer transfer
from
such an elastic noisy channel
okay what we have shown is that for this
particular alpha and beta oblivious
transfer can be constructed using
encodings of
length seven
but
for which values of alpha and beta does
there exist
capacity inverting encodings
alternately
for which values of alpha and beta does
capacity inversion occur
okay let me go ahead and again prove it
using some pictures
so this is a graph which will represent
the set of feasible parameters the
y-axis will represent the flip
probability in the honest receiver case
and the x-axis will represent the flip
probability of the adversarial receiver
case
if you use encodings of length one
we never have capacity inversion
if we use
encodings of length two then we gain a
small range of feasible parameters
okay let me explain how to uh
interpret this graph suppose the
adversarial flip probability is 0.1
then
all these values of alpha
experience capacity inversion
now if you are using encodings of
greater length
more and more parameters
start experiencing capacity inversion
this space keeps on increasing
increasing increasing until it hits a
limiting curve i call it limit beta
curve
let me give an example of what kind of
parameters our protocols can achieve
so suppose there exists a binary
symmetric channel in which
the honest receiver has alpha equal to
and um
adversarial receiver has beta equal to 5
then our protocol constructs oblivious
transfer from such versions of elastic
binary symmetric channel an alternate
way of interpreting it is that suppose
the best
receiver in the market is 95 percent
accurate then we can design protocols
which implement oblivious transfer even
assuming that the honest party uses a
weak receiver which is only 70 percent
accurate
so
what we have
proven is that when alpha and beta is
bounded by limit beta then there exists
a secure protocol for oblivious transfer
from these elastic variants of binary
symmetric channel
the question here is what exactly did we
gain
how much did we improve the prior state
of the art
for last 25 years there have been lots
of work on
constructing oblivious transfer from
noisy channels and weak variants of it
using these techniques in our setting
the only feasibility parameters known
for our case was this small municipal
fraction
represented in this green
let me give an example
suppose
the best antenna in the market is 95
accurate
then these protocols need to assume that
the honest party has uses an antenna
which is 94 accurate
there is only one percent gap it's not
at all satisfactory
so our work
adds this huge range of parameters
and we can even assume that the honest
party has a 70 accurate receiver
can we go beyond this
it's not known i conjecture yes indeed
we can
and
mostly because i believe so and there
are no impossibility results known
to conclude i just want to say
that this notion of
capacity inversion is extremely
fundamental topic property of
noisy channels and i think it can be
leveraged in general information
theoretic cryptographic protocol design
it's clear actually that there are some
very low hanging fruits as well that we
can try to attack like we can try to
increase the parameter space for what we
have done in our work or we can also try
considering other variants of noisy
channels like awgn channels
the last problem is something which i
like the most
i want to quantitatively find out what
is the maximum limit of efficiency that
we can get given n copies of a
particular noisy channel how many copies
of ots that i can
implement think about it it's just an
analog of the problem of capacity in
error correcting codes that we are
posing for secret for mpcs and even this
fundamental quantity is not known with
that thought i would like to conclude my
talk thanks
what is the length of the inquiry in
terms of it's a
for constant constant alpha beta there
exists a constant
for which
a constant encoding
we don't have a closed form formula we
have a algorithm which finds it
in a logarithmic time like whatever the
encoding length is we can find it in
logarithmic time
one always thing to try in order to get
better parameters is to look at the
softer target like a defective oblivious
transfer where the defect in
is smaller than that of privacy and then
maybe the honest user can use not just
the max but also the things below
actually um there is a separate project
where we are exploring these things
in the project of combiners and
extractors so for ot we are considering
these kind of problems there
yes
or common perhaps that if if you compare
to earlier work on fantasy channels you
should in fairness i think also remember
that those protocols had to cope with
the fact that also the sender could
modify the channel yes
there may be a reason why it's hard to
get it no yes i mentioned this that
in unfair channels both receiver and
adverse and the sender can change
the channel characteristic and that
causes
existence of strong impossibility
results
so that that's also i mean
did you have a comment on this i'm i'm
thinking that if it's the motivation or
for considering elastic channels is that
maybe the the the center device but
maybe the receiver bites are bigger
antenna but also contemplate maybe the
receiver sends a stronger signal
but that is detectable right like it you
can detect that oh you have sent a
larger signal and i said i'm not going
to participate in the protocol anymore
so we didn't want that model actually
but by the way we conjectured that our
techniques are going to be also useful
for the unfair channel technique like
the impossibility result is subsumed by
encodings of length 2 in our setting i
think
we conjecture that it's going to be
useful for that
here and go to the break maybe we can
take this offline